the packers were not afraid of the snow
they weren't afraid of the tennessee
titans last night
now when we picked the game on wednesday
i'm not making excuses
it sounds like i can't go ahead and make
the excuse i mean look it hey it works
for coaches and players
they say i'm not making excuses and then
they articulate the excuse
so i'm not making excuses but here's my
excuse we didn't know it was going to
snow we knew it was possible
we didn't know it was going to snow when
we picked the game i don't know that i
would have picked it any differently
but the packers kudos to them showing up
in the bad
weather conditions and it was closed for
a while it was 1914 at one point after
ryan tannehill did that
shot out of a cannon run to the end zone
and unlike daniel jones didn't fall flat
on his face even though he would have
had an excuse even though he wouldn't
have been making excuses
there's snow on the ground the packers
just steamrolled the titans and the
packers now
are still not clinching the number one
seed in the nfc but all they need to do
is beat the bears and they get it
uh packers look pretty good chris if
they can play like that every week
they're gonna be
the team that makes it to tampa bay in
february well it's
it's it played out just the way we said
that they want a game to play out right
mike they get on you early
they get a lead you know yeah they can
dial it back maybe not take too many
chances on offense but they're still
aggressive enough to where okay it's
still aaron rodgers and if guys are open
he's gonna hit him but then
it's we don't have to worry about
stopping the run as much
and now we can rush the passer and jair
alexander and you know
darnold savage who's a first round pick
at safety and we can fly around in the
back end
that's the way they want to play
football i mean that that's it right
there
and when green bay executes the way they
do
you know in most games early like that
where it's almost
just about every damn game with green
bay and aaron rodgers where
the first two drives of the game they're
gonna
they're gonna get 10 points at least i
mean it's just it's almost a given
they're almost unstoppable on the first
and second drives of the football game
because of rogers
because of the first 15 or the first 10
you know plays that are game planned all
week to
to fit specifically against that team
and then rogers his ability to
you know be the general at the line of
scrimmage and get them in the right play
i mean it really you know rogers was
phenomenal last night i think he
cemented
his mvp in my opinion i don't i don't
why i don't nope no well a couple of
reasons a couple reasons first of all
they don't have the number one seed if
they don't get the number one seed i
think it
it becomes difficult to overcome patrick
mahomes in the one seat and second look
it's 50 human beings voting on this the
fact that there's this sense rogers is
politicking for it
could turn some people off the fact that
he was whining
recently about not getting it in 2012
and not whining he's just
just talking yeah he's not making an
excuse he's just making no you're just
being online
and being a guy that talks openly like
you like people
talk fine yes well yeah except except
when it's about why don't i have more
stuff
hey why didn't you give me this why
didn't i get that you let others make
that argument for you not
yourself directly all i'm saying is it
could alienate some of the voters in a
close race
and when you look at the fact that
patrick mahomes may end up with 5 000
passing yards for the second time in
three years
that is going to help his cause so the
packers
i believe have to get the one seed and
right now we would say they probably
will but you know the packers can get it
the saints can get it the seahawks can
get it it's a weird
cluster of permutations which is good it
gives all three teams reason to play
their starters this weekend
when otherwise we've seen week 17 the
best teams
in one of the conferences they don't
need to but
but still i i think that the human
factors here need to be taken into
account well that's
then there's really something wrong
that's that's all because
we're gonna get into that newsflash
newsflash there's something wrong with
human beings subjectively voting on
awards that go to other human beings
that have no real accepted definition of
what it even means to be the mvp
these ap awards are crap top to bottom
chris
they are the whole process stinks 50
people
plenty of whom have no business having a
vote sorry i'll say it i know it's not
the airing of grievances dave but i've
said it before i'll say it again
and this whole one vote per person thing
is flawed as well
because you put all the eggs in one
basket instead of saying
first place second place third place
that's how it should be like it is with
the heisman trophy so
yeah the whole thing's flawed news flash
the whole thing's flawed
but that that that's how i filter
what i think is going to happen i know
it's going to be the product of a flawed
process and i think that flawed process
is more likely to land on my homes than
rogers at this
point wow that i mean i don't think so
i don't you yeah like rogers got to
throw like three interceptions and maybe
them lose the game
if he does if they can lose the game
this week to in my opinion and
if he just has a good get good day
they're going to be people all these
mvp what does it mean what does mvp mean
right you tell me yeah
the ap doesn't tell anybody what it
means what does it mean okay well i
don't play in the league
no i'm most valuable i think it's a
combination of like best player in the
league and who's most valuable
to their team within those two like
realms right there and i think how much
50 50 47 53 well it depends on who
you're comparing
it well okay i know but we'll do it for
them and maybe they can tune in and
learn so here we go
so if roger we know mahomes has a little
more talent all right we'll say that we
know that
but it's not by a much then you talk
about value to the team
we know both are extremely valuable but
one guy
has an all-star cast around him the
other guy
has a solid cast around him that guy has
played better individually with the
solid cast than the guy with
the all-star cast around him and the guy
with the all-star cast around him
has made some vital mistakes this year
but he's got an all-star cast around him
so yeah they've come out come away and
won football games
i i look at green bay and just go you
know rogers has done
more for their team this year and means
more to them
in my opinion the mahomes either way
they're both awesome we know that we pay
money uh right now kova 19 to go to a
super bowl to watch rogers in the home
sign me up i'll take the test i'll wear
the masks
i'll go to the game if that's what we're
gonna see but that's
just my take and either way green bay
was phenomenal last night to get us back
on track
well no but but you know what this is
this is an interesting rabbit hole that
that you've pulled us down and i haven't
done anything to resist it good
think about this think about this if it
is
chiefs packers super bowl 55 tampa bay
when do we find out who the mvp is when
do we find out yeah the night before the
night before the game right
what if what if that what if the guy
who isn't the mvp uses that
as the last little middle finger
take this red hot poker up you know
something you would say up your butt joe
boo right exactly
uh but but but what i mean wouldn't that
be a factor
wouldn't that be a factor wouldn't that
make aaron rodgers
even more determined i think it's more
of a factor for rogers if mahomes wins
the mvp than it is from a homes if
rogers wins it but wouldn't that be a
factor the next night well i don't know
mahomes is the one that's counting on
the field and doing all these things
when he feels slighted
you know oh gosh he's complaining about
where he got drafted i mean no
all right but yeah i hear you that would
add
amazing intrigue to the game and
i don't know both i think would be
bitter i think both of them would be
bitter as hell
if they lost the mvp race the night
before the super bowl
do i think it's going gonna affect them
it's the damn super bowl and legacy's on
the line so i think they'll be ready to
go whether they win
or lose that mvp but yeah it's just a
little something extra you're right it's
a little something extra i'm not gonna
lie there will be a little something
extra there's no doubt about that
there's no doubt and it would be great
to see that match up i mean that would
be candy
uh but but either way the way they
looked last night
was very impressive and i do think
rogers is the mvp as we sit here right
now
but you disagree and
and it's not like rogers has no help
whatsoever when devante adams is healthy
rogers is a better quarterback let's
hear quickly since i should have done
this earlier but better never than late
or something
here's aaron rodgers talking about the
victory and the performance of his
top receiver perhaps only receiver
devonte adams
i think we've all heard about the
conversation about us not being enough
good teams and you know not responding
and playing a complete game and
this was our response being with that
guy is it's allowed me to
you know know what true greatness is
uh well you look they are great and uh
they've been great this year
and you know this notion of how
motivated aaron rodgers was by the
selection of jordan love
it's kind of a slippery thing and you
can hear people debate it and they'll
take the same side of the or the
different sides of the same issue if
they talk about it long enough
it either does motivate him it doesn't
motivate him it did
contribute to his performance this year
or it didn't i think it did i think it
did i think he channeled it in a
positive way
i think mark murphy and brian gudekunst
are geniuses because i think that was
part of the reason
why they drafted jordan love frankly
they'd never admit it but i think that's
one of the reasons why they did it
it is the red-hot poker for aaron
rodgers in his final years with the
packers
and it's worked and it's delivered
something i didn't think we'd see from
the packers this year and kudos to the
packers
and aaron rodgers and now they're on the
brink of being the one seed and if
they're the one seed and they get
weather like they got last night they're
going to tampa yeah agreed
i mean you know we didn't like they're
they're amazing at home
in that field and mike you know i
i like you i always stand pat with like
whoever i picked on our thursday podcast
i go with on sunday night i'm not trying
to confuse my life
i will say with the snow yesterday i was
close to going hmm
i don't know i don't know if i like the
titans chances rogers green bay in this
snow they're accustomed to it rogers can
throw the ball through any elements like
this i had no
issues about that and you saw the
tennessee was a little flustered by it
all together
let me also say this can i apologize to
devonte adams for not having on my top
10 wide receiver list because
that was probably my most egregious
mistake
of the past year as far as football
i don't know i think it was i think it
was i'm sorry yourself my lists have
been pretty damn good
my draft evaluations are pretty damn
good but he
is on fire right now and playing
phenomenal football
and while i don't sit here and say oh
he's the best receiver in football i'm
not trying to disrespect him
he's certainly top five top ten
without a doubt and i dropped the ball
there so i apologize to you mr adams no
disrespect ever was intended
it's just part of my job the other thing
i'll say though within this too
like i i mean i just was sitting there
and i'm just this is fanboy stuff but
i'm going to bring you down
the wormhole again i don't care is that
the best quarterback
like pass catcher combo in football
right now is there a better one
does mahomes and kelsey beat that is
there something else i'm missing
i just don't know to me right now rogers
and adams
seems unstoppable even when he's covered
rogers throws a perfect throw
and he catches the ball i mean they're
just they're they're amazing right now
i think the fact that it's just adams
and i don't mean any
disrespect i know there are other
receivers and tight ends yeah but
they literally all have like one catch
and one
yeah right right but but i think the
fact that
that adams doesn't have that other guy
like
kelsey has tyreek hill that makes adams
more special
because with hill and kelsey it's picked
your poison with
with atoms they there's no poison to
pick they know who they're going to try
to defend
and they can't they just can't they
can't stop him
they can't keep the ball from going to
him and aaron rodgers is going to find
him and deliver it
and yeah i mean the only key uh is
keeping adams on the field we've seen
him get injured the past couple of years
and it's a different offense when he's
off the field so
maybe they should go back and take a
closer look at the contract that he
signed a couple of years ago and maybe
give him a little sweetener yeah
seriously i remember i remember he
signed a contract that i thought was
you know look hey if you're happy with
it that's fine but in comparison to
other deals i remember thinking he sold
himself
short and maybe the packers want to
swoop in and get that taken care of
before it becomes a problem because he
deserves more
than what he's currently that makes you
think of them differently last night he
yeah well well absolutely i mean look i
mean but it's every week
it's every week it's every there isn't
an
off week for rogers and adams if adams
is healthy
that threat is always there so i still
don't think that they could beat the
chiefs
but i'd love to see him try yeah i know
what i mean a game like last night
does make you think differently about
them as a football team
you know they showed some true
physicality and toughness on both sides
of the football
in areas where we thought tennessee
would have an advantage
so i give them a lot of credit there i
really do because i wasn't sure they
could stand up to that challenge and
play that type of football
you know definitely um but rogers was
great
the defensive line was great the titans
can't
can i just say this about them they
can't just like it can't always be like
eight guys at the line of scrimmage and
just say we're gonna run the ball
like this is the nfl okay
i don't give a damn how crappy a defense
is when you got eight guys in a row
and derek henry at tailback and you're
just going we're gonna run it we're
gonna run it we're gonna run it
i you i this is not the cowboys of 1992
you can't just say you're gonna do that
like they need to at some point
you know spread the field a little bit
and you can run the football that way
too they started off the second half
doing that but they're they're playing
in the team's hands a little bit at
times would be
with their ability to just go we're
going to crowd the box crowd the box
they might send one or two guys out in a
res on a route
uh and and they make it easier to stop
them at times i think a little bit there
and become a little too predictable with
the way they run the football
and i don't think they give derek henry
enough room to make magic happen
well and especially when the one flaw in
henry's game is he needs two or three
steps
he needs it right so if you can get to
him quickly
and knock him down he's not gonna he's
not gonna kill you so the more guys you
have in position to swarm
before he can get the head of steam
that's it
he's not gonna he's not gonna bust
through the first level and just
and either run past or run through
whoever gets in his way
so uh yeah and look they've got work to
do now
they've got they're going to be facing a
texans team that as john mcclane of the
houston chronicle pointed out last night
probably won't put desean watson
in harm's way which should help the
titans win the division and then we'll
see if they can address their flaws for
the postseason
uh there are many places you can go for
fairly superficial analysis there's only
one place to go to get the true insight
the hard-hitting take as to what
happened in a football game
and that is magic johnson's packers
having home field advantage in the
playoffs they will be tough to beat
because of the cold weather and the snow
does he have
working for him does he have like a
robot working for him i mean what is
that
here's my question is he is he messing
with
us like thurman merman messing with bad
sam
is he messing i think he's messing with
us
or or someone dropped him on his head
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports